les Torontois n'ont plus que quelques
heures avant de passer au vote près de 2
millions de résidences ont appelés aux
urnes dans cette élection où
s'affrontent un nombre records de
candidats et certaines candidatures sont
pour le moins nusité notamment celle
d'un chien et de son maître dans cette
course moins d'une dizaine de candidats
se sont illustrés parmi eux Olivia ciao
qui mène dans les sondages depuis
plusieurs semaines
l'ex concerne municipal et ancienne
député néo-démocrates aux fédérale
estime que son message assure allier les
électeurs à la recherche d'une ville
plus abordable un peu une surprise de
voir Madame ciao sortir comme candidate
mais une fois que celle lancée dans la
course
elle a vraiment moins optimisé la vote
de la du centre gauche et de la gauche
la veuve de Jack letton est depuis un
moment la cible des attaques de ses plus
proches adversaires et à la veille du
scrutin les candidats plus à droite
appellent au vote stratégique pour
vaincre madame ciao
appuyez par dogford l'ancien chef de
police Mark Sanders interpelle
directement les électeurs courtisés par
certains candidats conservateurs eux qui
selon lui ne sont en mesure de vaincre
madame ciao merci
la protéger du maire sortant le logement
et le transport en commun se sont encore
une fois imposés dans les priorités des
électeurs la question des impôts
fonciers a aussi beaucoup retenu la
tension je pense que la thématique la
plus importante c'est celle des services
publics et des impôts et donc
est-ce qu'on peut avoir une ville
intéressante avec le taux d'imposition
actuelle le prochain maire aura du pain
sur la planche il devra combler un trou
budgétaire de près d'un milliard de
dollars dans les finances de la ville
ici Yannick Lepage Radio-Canada Toronto